One of the interesting aspects
of the story of Christ and the
Christian story in general, is
that within the story of Christ,
you see that Christ chose his
own betrayer. And this, of
course, is a testimony to how in
a larger sense, in Christianity,
we have the sense that
Antichrist will rise out of
Christianity, will appear as a
side effect or a kind of strange
deformation of the Christian
message. And so there are
several aspects to Antichrist.
I'm going to look especially at
one, which I called something
like weaponized compassion. And
we will see this version or this
aspect of antichrist, especially
in the story of Judas Iscariot,
who is the disciple that Christ
chose, who ultimately ended up
betraying him.
And so there are several aspects
of antichrist. There are two
aspects which we could see
almost as something like opposed
to each other or two extremes of
what Antichrist looks like. The
one that people usually tend to
look upon is the Empire idea of
Antichrist or the beast, this
notion of Rome as being
something like the horror of
Babylon, all this kind of
imagery of Antichrist. And it's
especially happened in the
Protestant Reformation where,
you know, the notion of the
relationship between the
Catholic Church and Rome was
related to a certain extent with
the idea of a parody of
Christ and of Christ's message
and something like Antichrist.
And there's something about
that which is interesting,
because there is an aspect in
the story of Antichrist
which is related to
St. Peter, because St. Peter is,
of course, the one who denies
Christ. St. Peter is also the
one who, although he is the
first one to recognise Christ,
he ultimately refuses one aspect
of Christ, refuses for a certain
amount of time, one aspect of
Christ's message, which is that
Christ must die. And when St.
Peter wants to oppose that,
wants to say that Christ will
not die on the cross, then that
is when Christ tells St. Peter,
"Get behind the Satan." And so,
of course, St. Peter is
important and there's a very
positive aspect of St. Peter,
which is true, and which is good
to understand.
But the story of Christ is very
complex, and contains all this
subtlety within it. And one of
the aspects of St. Peter, of the
strength of the Christian story
and the strength of the, let's
say, the possibilities of
Christianity, also has a dark
side, which is the possibility
of pride, the possibility of not
thinking that Christianity is
about self sacrifice, and the
willingness to die for others
and the willingness to die in
general. But there is also a
flip side to that image of
Antichrist, which is that
although Christ tells us to care
for the poor, tells us to tend
to the orphan and the widow and
to care for the weak, to be
attentive to the margins,
be attentive to those that are
usually excluded, cast out,
there's also a dark side to
that, which is the Antichrist
aspect of it, which is something
that we could call weaponized
compassion. And this version of
weaponized compassion appears in
the other disciple in the story
of Christ that has to do with
this Antichrist aspect and that
is, of course, Judas Iscariot.
Judas Iscariot is the one who
betrays Christ ultimately,
betrays him with a kiss. And
this is related to this
weaponized compassion that we
see in the story of Judas. And
that we will especially see in
the story where Mary of Bethany
washes Christ's feet. So I'm
going to read the text with you.
And we're going to look at
what's going on in the story.
And what that can mean for us,
especially today, because we are
faced with some of that. And it
tends to confuse Christians,
just like also when Christianity
is strong and Empire-like it can
also let's say, confuse some
Christians as to what the real
goal of Christianity is.
And so the texts appeared in the
Gospel of St. John, chapter 12,
starting at verse 1. 'Six days
before the Passover, Jesus
therefore came to Bethany, where
Lazarus was whom Jesus had
raised from the dead, so they
gave a dinner for him. Martha
served and Lazarus was one of
those reclining with him at
table. Mary therefore took a
pound of expensive ointment,
made from pure nard and anointed
the feet of Jesus and wiped His
feet with her hair. The house
was filled with the fragrance of
the perfume but Judas is
Iscariot, one of his disciples,
who was about to betray him,
said, "Why was this ointment not
sold for 300 denari and given to
the poor?" He said this, not
because he cared for the poor,
but because he was a thief. And
having charge of the money bag,
he used to help himself to what
was put into it. Jesus said,
"Leave her alone, so that she
may keep it for the day of my
burial, for the poor you always
have with you, but you do not
always have me."'
And so what's going on in this
story? We have an image of a
woman who takes very expensive,
takes something very expensive,
and focuses it on worship. Now
we could understand that as many
things, of course, we can
understand it in general of the
idea of creating beauty in order
to worship God, we could also
understand it in terms of the
amount of attention, the amount
of time and resources and
valuable things that we put into
the service of worshipping
Christ.
And so the trick that Judas
wants to take is he wants to
take a good, which is caring for
the poor. Now, of course, caring
for the poor is a good, not only
is it a good, but it is a good
that Christ Himself has asked us
to do. Christ is constantly
telling people to care for the
poor, and to help the weak. But
he's trying to make that good
into the highest good. And this
is where there is a problem. And
so he tells the woman that she
should not have used this
expensive thing, this precious
thing, to worship Christ, but
that she should have used it and
sold it and given it to the
poor. Now, what's interesting in
this is, this is why I called it
weaponized compassion. Because
ultimately, Judas doesn't care
for the poor. What Judas wants
is to acquire power for himself.
And so he wants her to sell this
for money, so that he can dip
into the money bag and take the
money for himself. Now, of
course, this is very specific in
the story. But you can
understand that in many ways,
which is that, many people can
use compassion, or use
compassion as a weapon in order
to acquire power for themselves.
Now, this is a temptation which
is becoming stronger and
stronger in the Christian
church. It is something which is
blinding many Christians to some
aspects of what is going on
around them. And because they
don't know how to react to it.
There is a tendency to make
people feel guilty about their
own Christian values, to make
them feel as if those very
Christian values, the very
Christian beliefs they have, is
somehow a compromise in
compassion. And that if they
were truly compassionate, they
would actually sacrifice their
own Christian beliefs.
The ultimate version of
something like this is in the
movie 'Silence', which many of
you have probably seen. In this
movie a Christian missionary is
sent to Japan. And the Christian
missionary is faced with a
serious problem, which is that
in trying to support the
Christian church there, the
Japanese authorities realise
that if we torture the
missionaries, we have a problem
because the missionaries are
willing to die for their faith.
But if we torture other people,
then that is putting the right
pressure on the missionaries,
because their own values, their
own compassion, will compel them
to deny their faith in order to
preserve the life of others. And
so, of course, I can't imagine
being in that situation. It's a
horrible situation to be in. And
I don't want to judge anybody
who's in this situation who
would have compromised or
fallen. But the very fact that
this is framed in the story,
that in the story there is a
sense in which although the
missionary denied his faith, and
ended up completely denying his
own belief in Christ and his own
attachment to God, ultimately
there was something holy about
that very action. And it's shown
that in the end, when he's
dying, and he's being cremated,
we see that there's a little
cross hidden on him or something
like that. And that is to show
that somehow the very denial of
his faith was done out of
compassion. And that this would
be the ultimate Christian act,
in a way, would be to deny your
faith out of compassion.
And so you can apply this
problem to many, many other
things. You can apply it, of
course, right now to many social
issues in which those social
issues are related to things
that Christians hold dear in
their values. But there is a
pressure, there's a pressure on
Christians, to, out of
compassion, to deny their own
stance. That is, not only have
compassion for the weak, have
compassion for the sinners, have
compassion for people who are
not able to hold the standard,
because who can? No one, no
Christian can hold the ultimate
standard that Christ lays out
for us. But that compromising on
your standard would be a more
Christian thing to do, than to
simply love others and be
compassionate while holding to
the highest standard. Now
there's a place where you see
that happen all the time. But
there's another aspect of this
which is going on right now,
which is related almost directly
to the story of Judas and the
notion of compromising worship
in the name of something else,
compromising worship, in the
name of compassion.
There is a narrative which is
being pushed, and which is very
strong. And it's strong, because
it's so long, it's enduring. You
know, it's been two years now,
where people are being told that
out of compassion - that
Christians shouldn't commune and
worship together, out of
compassion for others. That is,
that out of a desire to preserve
the weak and to preserve the
helpless people
should sacrifice worship, and
should not practice the
Christian practices of singing
together before their God, of
communing together to the Holy
Sacraments. And this is a very,
very fascinating thing, because
you can see that in a way it is,
it is a very strong tool. It is
a very strong tool because it
dives right into what Christians
believe. And it dives right into
the Christian's high values and
tries to set those values up as
the highest above what is more
important, which is worship and
submission to God. And you see
it, you actually see it very
interestingly, you can notice
that if you look at the
difference between Pope Benedict
and Pope Francis, it's very
fascinating, because Pope
Benedict wanted to bring back
worship. And so he brought out
some old crosses that were in
treasuries and wanted to kind of
show the beauty with vestments,
and this beautiful
aspect of the Christian
liturgical services and
Christian worship. And he was
eviscerated, he was eviscerated
by the media, eviscerated by
people, ultimately, who hate
Christianity, let's be honest.
But nonetheless, there was a
manner in which people gobbled
it up, and people completely
gave in to this narrative. And
now here comes Pope Francis, who
is the very opposite, who tends
to, let's say, play down the
worship aspect of the church and
play up the social aspect of the
church, play up the idea of
helping the poor, and there's
absolutely nothing wrong - Of
course, it is wonderful for
Christians to help the poor, but
the notion that we should, the
notion that worshipping Christ
is somehow bad, and that putting
valuable things in the service
and worship of God is somehow
horrible and disconnected.
Whereas helping the poor is
something that everybody loves,
and everybody finds is
beautiful, I think is definitely
an issue. And it's an issue that
although I sympathise with
Christians who struggle to see
the normal hierarchy, this is
actually the normal hierarchy of
being. This is really
representing the manner in which
attention to the highest,
worship of God, you know,
placing yourself in the right
position towards God, alone and
together into communion. And,
you know, engaging in the
liturgical dance, engaging in
the grand singing and dancing of
worship is more important than
the social actions of the
church. And of course, I know
some people are gonna watch this
and going to get angry and think
that I am somehow diminishing or
bringing down the idea of
helping the poor and of course
not, I spent seven years of my
life as a volunteer in Africa in
the desire just to serve Christ
in that manner. But nonetheless,
I still need to re-emphasize the
natural, the normal hierarchy of
things, which is that if you try
to sacrifice the top part for
the second part, you are going
to break down and you can see
that in many of the churches
that have embraced social
justice, no manner how they
phrase it as their highest
value, higher than their creed,
higher than their own original
beliefs, higher than the values
which were given to them, you
know, from the apostles all the
way - Then, and they're willing
to even sometimes criticize
scripture, criticize
the saints, in order to
bring about this social justice
transformation that they want.
That's not going to work, it's
going to break down, it's going
to lead to a breakdown, because
it doesn't follow the normal -
If you focus on secondary goods
as the highest good no matter
how good it is, it will
ultimately lead to a breakdown.
One of the key ways to
recognise if what is being used
or what is being promoted is
something like weaponized
compassion is to look at the
power aspect. Because one of the
ways that we can see it in the
story of Judas is that Judas is
telling someone else to be
compassionate, and is
reproaching someone else for not
being compassionate with the
purpose of gaining power for
themselves. And so this is the
best way to see whether or not
this is weaponized compassion.
And I think that we have seen
plenty of that in the past two
years. We have seen plenty of
authorities tell us that we need
to act in this or that way, in
order to be compassionate. And
what's interesting is that, you
know, on the one hand, there's
this idea that you are not being
compassionate, you are being
selfish by not doing this or
that. But then when you look
behind you the same authorities
telling you that are holding a
massive baseball bat over your
head. And the consequence for
not being compassionate is that
you will feel the brunt of their
raw power on you. And you'll
also notice that ultimately the
action that they want you to
pose is to the increase of their
power on you, and the increase
of their power on others. And so
this is the way in which you can
recognise weaponized compassion,
it's that, it is ultimately a
making you feel bad about
something, in order to acquire
power for the people who are
promoting this.
Compassion is something which is
freely given. Compassion is
something which we should always
be examining ourselves to see
whether or not we are being
compassionate, and what is the
motivation of our actions. We
should not be trying to impose
compassion on others. This is
something which you do not see
in the Christian story, you
know. That is, there is no law
towards compassion, there is no
rule which makes you
compassionate. You can follow
all the rules you want,
compassion is a disposition of
the heart, compassion is a
disposition of the person, it is
not about rules and about
following this or that thing.
You could act in ways that look
very compassionate on the
outside and are very selfish
inside, and vice versa. And so,
compassion is not something
which is subject to the law, it
is something which is subject to
the heart. And this is, of
course, the very difference that
Christ brings to us, which is
the difference between the
externals and the external law,
which is useful and helpful, and
the inner true reason of why
someone is acting. And so when
you see someone or when you see
an organisation try to impose
compassion by law, or try to
make you feel as if by not being
compassionate you are going to
receive the full brunt of the
modern state, then we have a
serious problem.
And so, of course, I do not want
to say that there isn't also the
other aspect of Antichrist,
which is the aspect of believing
that Christianity is a political
weapon, believing that
Christianity is a tool for
nationalism. All these things
exist, and they exist now, let's
be honest, the prideful aspect
of the Antichrist. But the other
aspect, the weaponized
compassion one, is an aspect,
which I think is more
misunderstood today. And it
would be helpful for us to
understand that as we continue
to face the crisis that we are
dealing with, you know, that
we've been dealing with for the
past few years.
And so I hope this was helpful
to help you understand some
aspects of this pattern and I'll
talk to you very soon.
As you know, the Symbolic World
is not just a bunch of videos on
YouTube. We are also a podcast,
which you can find on your usual
podcast platform. But we also
have a website with a blog and
several very interesting
articles by very intelligent
people that have been thinking
about symbolism on all kinds of
subjects. We also have a clips
channel, a Facebook group. You
know, there's a whole lot of
ways that you can get more
involved in the exploration and
the discussion of symbolism.
Don't forget that my brother
Matthieu wrote a book, called
The Language of Creation, which
is a very powerful synthesis of
a lot of the ideas that I
explore. And so please go ahead
and explore this world. You can
also participate by, you know,
buying things that I've
designed, t-shirts with
different designs on them. And
you can also support this
podcast and these videos,
through Paypal or through
Patreon. Everybody who supports
me has access to an extra video
a month and there are also all
kinds of other goodies and tiers
that you can get involved with.
So everybody, thank you again
and thank you for your support.